which is you know, the state's
defensive coordinator and
Dennis Allen who has had Tom
Brady's number. He's eating his
lunch. Now, multiple times. What
is it? Been four out of
five matchups that he's gotten
them. Only the playoff one is
the only game that Tom Brady
is one against the Saints and
basically Brady's bullied every
other defensive coordinator,
except in a salad. So what does
he know about? Tom Brady that
the other guys don't.
Well, he knows the exact same
game plan. And I tell you, if
you got, if you have the
Personnel, you got those big
guys up front and I told you
this in the pregame show.
You can rattle Tom. Brady
played with Tom. I played
against Tom. I've seen it.
I covered him basically 13
years of his career.
And if you put that inside
pressure, on time, he gets
nervous.
And if you hit them you make
them uncomfortable in a pocket.
He's going to hold the ball, but
the second part to it and
I thought they did a great job.
Look at, look at the tight
man-to-man carbon.
At the tight man-to-man
coverage, what they say, Tom?
Brady, releases 2.5 S. He can't
do that because the coverage
the rush, those guys are making
a move around Chauncey Gardiner
Johnson. That's another God. I
want
to talk to you about now. You
talking about
Jalen Ramsey? That's that's a
cheap. That's that's Jalen
Ramsey about 18 million dollars
cheaper.
Okay, that's who he is. He is an
absolute football player.
He can play any position. He
brings an energy. He makes
plays, he's sacks the
quarterback, he can, I mean, he
does it all and you You see he's
not intimidated. He's
telling Tom Brady. We here we
here to kick your butt. They
stepped up man.
Dennis Allen. This guy should be
considered at for head
coach. No question about it. His
defenses have been great.
He's a steady type of
personality. He's a good guy.
He definitely deserves
consideration.
I'm not going to say that the
Bucks would have won this game
if they still had some of their
guys, right. As soon as as soon
as you have no Godwin. And now
you have no Mike Evans. You're
already without Antonio Brown.
Now, there's no letter for
that. I mean they basically
didn't have it.
It's that pointed Brady's out
there with a bunch of guys who
probably more than anything.
He's played with lesser
receivers over his career. We
talked about that on Sunday,
but just to have the Reps in the
chemistry with these guys.
He wasted all those reps on the
guys who were out of the game
and hurt. But I mean for them to
lose a game at home where
all they have to do is score
more than nine mean Tom. Brady
hasn't been shut out in 15 years
and I think the reason is
and
give Dennis Allen a ton of
credit just because he's done
it over and over again, but not
a not very many defenses can
Rush The passer across the board
with Davenport with
Tuttle, with David on Yamada
with Cam, Jordan, who missed the
prior week. So I have fresh
legs coming back and he looked
fresh the way. He was flying
around that football field, but
they also have five great cover
guys to have the combination of
the rush and the cover players.
I can't think of another defense
that it's as dominant
on both ends of the spectrum.
That's just a hard combination
to find and Brady took it right
on the chin.
And you forgot about mention the
linebackers, the morrow
Davis is a terrified middle
linebacker. He is absolutely
fantastic. We talked about him.
He can hit, he can tackle, he
can cover, he can Blitz, he can
do it, all. And Kwon,
Alexander, like want Alexander.
He was a first-round, draft
choice, and he didn't work out
for San Francisco and he kind of
bounced around, but it seems
like he's found a home, you
know, in New Orleans. He thinks
he looks like his old self like,
athletic fast Making
Place celebrating, so he's
brought him a
lot of energy. A lot of juices.
Well,
that's a great point because I
remember Quan Alexander covered
Gronk. How many times? You see
Gronk, run that route. He runs
it right to the linebacker and
he turns around and breaks
right back to the sideline. And
when you try to break back to
styling,
Quan was all over him. He was
running to the sideline before
Gronk even decided that he was
going to go that direction. So
you got to give credit to all
these guys and Demario Davis.
Mammy, when I was watching the
week, eight game, the Mario
Davis
was going screen to the right.
The whole defense was running
to the right before the play.
So, yes, he has all
the physical tools. But probably
more than anything, his mental
and Leadership stuff that just
lining up the defensive backs
talking. I line up the defensive
front.
He appears to me to be the
leader of that entire defense
and you see what, what they're
producing. Imagine if
the Saints had a quarterback
man. If it weren't taysom Hill,
we'd
be talking about a potential
Super Bowl team here.
Brother, I was just sitting here
thinking the same thing.
I'm like, how frustrating is it
to have a top defense? And I've
been there, we had the worst
offense in the league in
the number one defense in the
NFL
and I was with the
charges back in 1998. I think it
was.
It's very frustrating,
but defensively, you have to
change your mindset and you
completely say, we're going to
forget about the offense. We're
going to try to score points.
We're going to get turnovers.
We're going to give them field
position. We're going to do
whatever we have to do
to make sure we make their life
easier. We can't depend on them
to win the football game. We
have to win a football game.
And that's just the change of
mindset.
That's right, and nobody wants
to talk about it. But Antonio
Brown now becomes one of the
most important pieces on Tampa
and one of the most important
pieces coming back in the whole
NFL because if they didn't have
him, they would be in a world
of trouble.
Who knows how long my Gavin's
going to miss with the hammy.
They have to have another wide
receiver on the outside and
probably Scotty Miller before.
Mike Evans gets back. It's
Scotty Miller and Antonio Brown
carrying that workload and Then
that group of tight ends that
they have. They're all going to
have to be actively involved in
the pass game. I would
think right.
I love Mike Evans. Love Chris
Godwin.
But Antonio Brown is their best
wide receiver.
I agree, Antonio Brown is their
best wide receiver, because he
can do it. All. He can go deep,
he can catch 10 yard out
routes. He can catch slant
routes and split the difference
like Odell and take it to the
house.
He's a hall-of-famer.
No question about it. He's
fantastic, man. One of the best
that I've ever seen and the
thing is like when I watch
receivers,
it's hard to impress me,
you know, from a receiving
standpoint. I played with Randy
Moss, who I just saw his work
ethic and things like That
I played with and against.
And I just think that
Antonio Brown is one of those
guys where he's a pain in
the butt off the field, but when
he gets on the field, he's just
totally locked in and that's the
type of guy to Tom likes.
He trust him. He can throw the
ball up. Antonio's
going to go get that football.
And you see why Tom Brady is
always fighting for me to be on
that roster, right? You didn't
even when coach Aryans doesn't
want them. It's moments exactly
like this and Tom Brady's lived
enough of these Seasons to know.
The guys get beat up
before the playoffs
and you have. To have depth is
specifically at the position
which are his Playmakers and
he's kept a be for that.